[Music]
hey man it's me kevin smith and we just
wrapped the first week of the
convenience tour i'm taking clerks three
out on the road 47 cities probably be 50
by the time we stop um showing the movie
doing a q a afterwards uh this little
piece you're about to see here was from
our first night
in new jersey when we did the opening
night show at the count basie so check
this out
welcome everybody to the very first
[ __ ] show of the convenience tour
um it took a minute to get here i've
been dreaming about this for for three
years back when we were on the reboot
roadshow tour i was like if they like
this [ __ ] oh my god they'd really love
clerks three and doing it here at the
count basie
thank you you're doing it here
doing it in this building absolutely
means a lot i've played the count basie
uh many times over the course of my
career and there was a magical [ __ ]
moment that happened like right
[ __ ] here uh years ago
a horrible time for everybody uh in the
area and in the country it was following
september 11th
it did a benefit for families in the
area who were affected by september 11th
and naturally there's a lot of people
who like work in wall street but lived
in the area and stuff so they wanted to
raise money for them and it was a slew
of uh local artists and famous [ __ ] and
stuff like [ __ ] bon jovi and joan
jett was there
south side johnny and of course uh bruce
springsteen was there and so they asked
me if i wanted to be the mc and i was
like absolutely uh hi welcome to the
show
thank you my name is kevin smith i'm
gonna host here tonight
so i'd come out and [ __ ] say some
funny things and then intro the next
artist they'd come out [ __ ] do their
set i didn't show somebody else a
speaker so forth all night long all
night long right back there in the wings
where jennifer's standing right now
the uh
[Applause]
the boss was standing there you know
because he was just getting ready he was
you knew when he was performing but he's
a
music fan so he was watching everybody
perform he knew them all anyway so he's
in the wings every time i'd come out
here and come back i would pass him and
we'd make eye contact and he would be
like give me one of these and i built
like that so you know he was the last
artist of the night um i'd seen him do a
private rehearsal here the night before
god bless you hope that's not [ __ ]
coveted and uh
we're just getting out of this [ __ ] um
so i'm backstage and uh right before
he's about to go on uh geraldo rivera
came out and he introduced a guy
who was given a [ __ ] huge check
uh to the to the charity and when i say
a [ __ ] huge check it was a novelty
huge check
but it was also for like a [ __ ] ton of
money and because of that you know he
was being given the honor of introducing
bruce and you know i was like oh all
right
i guess the rich get richer you know
[ __ ] so
he goes out geraldo introduces this guy
money guy gives the check and [ __ ] and
then he comes to the point where he's
going to introduce bruce and this is how
he introduces bruce he doesn't [ __ ]
say his name he goes and now a man who
needs no introduction and then he
[ __ ] walked off stage
and bruce was like i guess that's me and
he came on a [ __ ] stage in the house
[ __ ] went nuts you know his [ __ ]
jersey icon legend and [ __ ] i was like
and he plugs in his guitar and i was
watching from the side and [ __ ] and i
was a little bitter at the fact that i
didn't get to introduce him and [ __ ] but
whatever is like i was about to watch a
[ __ ] front row performance of bruce
springsteen and [ __ ] he plugs in his
[ __ ] guitar and before he sings a
single [ __ ] note classiest move on
earth
god goes up to the mic and he goes i'm
not getting started till the emcee comes
out and introduces me
and i [ __ ] raced out here
[Applause]
giddy as [ __ ] gave him the biggest
[ __ ] hug and i was like ladies and
gentlemen a man who needs no
introduction
ladies and gentlemen
the boss himself
and now we're back here for this man and
this is like always in my head and heart
i knew we would start the tour in jersey
just like we did the last one it makes
sense this is the motherland the cradle
of [ __ ] civilization and
yes
this is where i'm from and you're gonna
see how much i love the great state of
new jersey in the movie you're about to
watch for the very first time since the
very first time i made a movie i got to
make a movie entirely in the great state
of new jersey man
doesn't that look fun oh my god don't
you want to be involved come out and see
the movie man clerks three the
convenience tour see it with me or you
can just see it on fathom event screens
uh september 13th all the way through
september 18th at participating theaters
near you but if you want to watch it
with me uh go to clerks3
dot movie and pick up tickets for the
convenience tour
uh it's nothing but fun man it's like
going to church every night where i'm
both the priest and jesus at the same
time man so come on join the
congregation kids quick stop open for
business the convenience store rolls
forward i'll see you next time till then
is kevin smith saying i assure you
clerks 3 is open
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the
aka ask kev anything every saga has a
ten year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
jay and sam bob get old i'm kevin smith
[Music]